skeleton twins I really enjoyed this
movie and you were at the the lovely
Kristen Wiig in this film and I think I
was looking at the movie and in the
movie you play her husband yeah but I
would think it wouldn't be hard to act
as if you're in love with her you're
always getting to do these movies where
you're with attractive I fell in love
with her you fell in love with her no I
mean it's like I always kind of you
laugh when when these actors like fall
in love with their co-stars but you can
see how it would happen I yeah but yeah
she's just so kind of sharp and funny
and yeah just very fun to be around yeah
I would see over the years interviewing
attractive women I've I've noticed how
it's like I always wonder that no you
wonder because what happens is what's
the signal you learn from the time that
you're 6 years old on if a woman who's a
tribe doesn't act with you moves towards
you sits next to you
and laughs at everything you say it
means they like you think if there were
like the 70s and you were single you
could go to Chasen's right after the
taping or dantana ah you're you're
mocking me for the life I don't have I'm
just saying imagine how great this is
great oh great it really could be so
you're saying that you really do fall in
love you sort of do fall in love with
you get crushes on these cuz you talk
with so many beautiful women I mean I
just I did this movie with Olivia Wilde
who's great and just a few weeks ago in
New York but I'd come home from work I
just kind of be watching TV and she'd be
on a L'Oreal commercial I'm hooked
there's my wife walking down the street
like waving at people hair perfectly
bouncing yeah I don't like where's my
L'Oreal money yeah what I was thinking
Indian she's got a great job yeah yeah
here's the cash yeah that's very
confusing for you yeah you are the
youngest of three boys is that right yes
okay and you went to an all-boys school
I I never went to an all-boys school do
you how do you get insights into women
if you're in all-boys school did you get
did your brothers tell you stuff yeah
know that it wasn't like you know like
the American Indian where like wisdom is
passed down through the ages there was
like a great deal of like misinformation
like it never yeah don't ever let them
know that you like home just whatever
you do just be cool don't laugh at their
jokes and don't be kind whatever you do
don't be kind what then they told you
that
oh yeah just the older guys okay don't
be kind got it never smile don't smile
okay got that but you do think they like
it when you don't smile and you don't
let I think there is part of them it
does like cuz I was always the guy that
was like hiya ladies good well no it was
and I hiya ladies nothing don't worry
invited me in the corner and he wouldn't
say anything had seemed wounded and
broken women all over hanging there
doing the cool guy routine yeah where
some somewhere in between what you did
you made that face when you described
what I did well but you I had a bought
it oh you two bought it yeah oh you and
I would have gone out
we have a clip here from the skeleton
twins where you're you're just you're
playing such a such a you're such a good
guy you're a good guy in this movie
you're a good lovable adorable guy are
you doing it to me right locking eyes
with you I'm telling you and when you
were looking at handy ow
wow that fire went out yours yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you